- THIS WEED
IS MAD TIGHT, YO.
- YEAH, MAN,
I'M SUPER HIGH, DOG.
- AH.
HEY, YO.
LET ME "AX" YOU A QUESTION
ON THE REAL.
- YEAH, YEAH, DOG.
YEAH, GO AHEAD, MAN.
- HEY, MAN,
WHERE MY DOOKIE GO?
- [chuckles]
OH.
WHAT?
- MY DOOKIE.
WHERE DO IT GO?
- IT GO DOWN IN THE TOILET,
[bleep], YOU KNOW THAT.
- NAH, MAN.
I AIN'T STUPID.
WHERE DO IT GO AFTER THAT?
- COME ON, MAN, QUIT PLAYING.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT--IT GOES DOWN THE SEWER,
YOU KNOW.
- EVERYBODY'S GO DOWN THERE?
- YEAH, EVERYBODY'S DOOKIE
GOES DOWN IN THE SEWER.
- WHERE MY DOOKIE GO
AFTER THAT?
- [scoffs]
IT WASHES OUT TO THE OCEAN.
I GUESS.
- HOLD UP, HOLD UP.
DOLPHINS SWIM
WITH MY DOOKIE?
- I DON'T KNOW, MAN.
I MEAN, I DON'T--
I REALLY DON'T KNOW.
- WE'RE IN THE OCEAN...
- YEP.
- WHAT HAPPENS
TO THE DOOKIE?
- I'M JUST TAKING A STAB AT--
LIKE A WILD GUESS,
ALL RIGHT,
THAT THE DOOKIE, LIKE,
PROBABLY GO UP IN THE AIR
AND, LIKE, EVAPORATES
AND THEN TURNS INTO A CLOUD
OR SOME [bleep].
- A DOOKIE CLOUD.
- OH, THIS [bleep].
- EVERYBODY'S DOOKIE
MIX UP,
GOES UP INTO A CLOUD,
AND THEN IT RAINS DOWN.
THAT'S GANGSTA.
- I JUST--
CAN WE STOP TALKING
ABOUT DOOKIE RIGHT NOW?
- I JUST THOUGHT OF SOMETHING.
- YES? WHAT IS IT?
WHAT IS IT, LEVI?
- THE PIECES OF MY DOOKIE...
- YEP?
- FALLS ON THE GROUND...
- THAT'S TRUE, YEP.
- AND BECOMES A PLANT.
- OKAY, OKAY, THAT'S GOOD.
NOW WE'RE DONE
WITH THE DOOKIE TALK, RIGHT?
- A DOOKIE PLANT...
- NO.
- THAT REACHES
TOWARDS THE SKY.
AHH.
HEY, SED.
- YEAH, LEVI?
- MAYBE IF MY DOOKIE
CAN MAKE IT OUT OF THE HOOD...
MAYBE WE CAN TOO.
- HUH.
MAYBE.
MAYBE, LEVI.